when talking or thinking about crypto
it's important to get the nomenclature
right
there are three terms of art that are
extraordinarily important to master and
to understand the distinction between
them
first there's the notion of
cryptocurrency
second there's the notion of a token or
a coin
and third there's the notion of an
initial token offering or an initial
coin offering
all are different
all have different legal implications
and let's burrow down and let's
understand the distinction among the
three a cryptocurrency
is a form of code that's supposed to
represent some kind of value
it's an electronic version of money or
at least that's how some people explain
it other people will dispute that
explanation
best example is probably something like
bitcoin where many people are using it
as a store of value on relatively rare
occasion it's actually used as a medium
of exchange but basically it's supposed
to represent value in a sense like a
dollar bill or you know some kind of
asset or gold or what have you
but in the form of a code that is scarce
that doesn't exist in an infinite form
we then have another form of crypto that
many people call coins or tokens
these are codes
that when used in a particular system
will perform a particular function
for example
you could imagine an environment in
which you can store your data
on the internet on other people's
computers
it's a little bit like airbnb but for
your data instead of for your body all
right
and when you've got that kind of a
system you're going to have to pay the
people who are providing the servers
where your data resides for the use of
their servers
you can use tokens or coins
bits of code in order to transfer that
value in that system
in addition you can imagine a situation
where you could pay at a restaurant
with tokens you could imagine tokens
that are designed specifically for ride
sharing systems you could imagine and
construct tokens and coins that could be
used for just about any economic
function in addition to the store of
value
third we come to initial coin offerings
or initial token offerings
these are fascinating situations
imagine somebody who wants to build a
system
that allows you to use tokens in order
to make restaurant reservations you get
paid for making reviews
you can get premiums and discounts for
ordering special bottles of wine or what
have you
so they build these tokens or they plan
to build these tokens
and they tell people look
we will sell you tokens for a system
that doesn't yet exist
and we will sell you these tokens and we
will raise a certain amount of money
and when we raise that money we will
then use it to launch the system and you
will have the tokens that you can then
use in the system and people have been
raising lots and lots and lots of money
around these initial coin offerings
in 2018 alone through july 10 billion
dollars has been raised for these
initial coin offerings
as you might imagine these are a bit
controversial
if you stop and if you think about
initial coin offerings
in the real world
it's as though somebody says you know i
have an idea i'm going to come up with
something oh i don't know beanie babies
and instead of
selling you stock
in the company that's going to make
beanie babies
i'm going to sell you beanie babies
before i've actually made any beanie
babies in other words i'm pre-selling my
inventory
and i'm using the cash that i raise by
pre-selling the inventory in order to
build the company and build the
inventory that i'm going to sell to you
it's not selling stock
the people who buy it don't have any
voting rights
all they're doing as a practical matter
is
buying the future inventory but in most
situations
or virtually all situations
they're buying the inventory at a price
that they hope will appreciate
and it's in part because of that
expectation of appreciation that
expectation of a profit that we wind up
with a fascinating legal issue
as to whether these initial coin
offerings are actually sales of
securities that need to be regulated as
security sales by the united states
securities exchange commission
and whether they also give rise to
private rights of action for the failure
to register these sales and for fraud
that in my view commonly occurs in
conjunction with these sales